there's a look at lance lynn on for his
22nd start looking for his 11th win with
an era of two and a quarter a lot of
strikeouts very few walks as you can see
right-handed left-handed doesn't make
much difference and the a's have an
early threat second and third nobody out
we're just underway
swing and a miss there's the first out
went to the high fastball he kept it
away from olson threw it by him
this is a huge strikeout it's just
barely out of the zone it just was
too close to take we told you about
olson being in swing mode and sometimes
when that happens
if it's close you're going after it
brings up jed lowry the switch batter
three and two on lowry the next offer
swinging a miss strike three what a
beautiful cutter that's from a pitcher
who doesn't care if he puts him on first
base he was going to get him out
out of the strike zone it's a perfect
cutter i mean it's not a strike but the
fact is it looked too tantalizing and
lowry could not lay off perfect pitch in
the perfect spot now harrison with two
outs lance stares in gathers the front
foot here's the 0-1 ground ball right
side cesar hernandez has it on hop and
lance lynn works around a trouble spot
in the first paul blackburn making his
first start of the 2021 campaign and the
sox are in business here in their half
of the first inning two on one away
and that ball crushed into the corner
hernandez will score abreu to third and
eloy's got a double
sox lead in the first exit velocity of
112. you want to throw a high fastball
by him he doesn't even come close to
doing that
that's rbi number 21.
and make no mistake that is one of the
reasons why jose is doing a better job
because now he's got eloy behind him he
knows that he can pick him up the weight
of the world is not on jose's shoulders
and alloy proves to be a wonderful
hitter as well as a slugger it's going
to load him up with nobody out for jed
lowry the at 60 pitches they followed
off a whole lot of pitches they've been
fairly selective they've worked him for
three walks which for him in two plus
innings is really unusual should be the
ninth pitch of the sequence
swinging a miss
one down
tough battle by lowry in the end that
was a wonderful two-seamer i mean this
one just diving away from lowry it
looked like a strike when it left his
hand and then just kept on moving away
josh harrison the second baseman for
oakland tonight 2-2
miss
putter away
harrison chucks the bat
he'll head back to the bench
two out in the inning and it will bring
up matt chapman at third martay second
olson first
this will get him out of it
anderson's got it base is loaded nobody
else no problem seth brown brown was a
pop out in the second foul territory
that one's hit well the left field's got
a chance lamb back and that baby's gone
seth brown goes the other way to tie up
the ball game at one well he got a
fastball up
and he drove it out of the park and kype
you can put it on the board yes we love
that from seth brown slants exited the
field and third base umpire was coming
on and lance
left his hat and glove on the railing on
top of the dugout so he took his belt
off from the dugout and tossed it out to
him
in the field of play to check
and he got tossed when he did that so
lance lynn's knight is done after four
innings he's been ejected from the game
monkana the runner at second good one is
at first 1-1 tie fourth inning
ground ball base hit
will score
goodwin will end up at third it's two to
one
rbi number 13 and
he just foiled the shift this looked
like a cutter away
they were playing him as an opposite
field hitter in the outfield
and straight away in the infield nobody
is there
sox do have the lead so the moncada walk
comes back to haunt blackburn sox back
on top two to one sergio roma on for the
49th time luis robert will bat with
burns of first and second 2-1 white sox
lead
robert
coming around third
and scoring is monkatta
a little deja vu robert knocking in his
teammate johan monkatta and it's three
to one
second run batted
in he got a slider up and took it
through the left side
that off night really helped him comes
back strong the run will be charged to
the starter blackburn what a series
robert has had
so here's elvis with andrew vaughn now
in the game he is in left field
towards center and robert falls down and
it goes over his head and rolls all the
way to the wall elvis sanders is digging
for second vaughn picks up the ball and
straight away center field and elvis
anders is going to stop at third with a
triple
robert came in and he just stopped he
was ready to catch it and he just
slipped grass kind of gave out a little
bit well it looks like it's a little
moist the playing surface we saw sebby
zabala earlier in the ball game on a
pass ball lose his footing
and luis robert here just digging the
spikes in trying to hit the brakes can't
do it makes a heck of an effort from his
backside
so the a's catch a break now they gotta
cash in and the asap runners at first
and third
towards center roberts sets up elvis
anders tags and elvis anders is gonna
come on home so sacrifice five for
starling marty to make it a three to two
game now runs the first and second only
one out liam comes on for the 50 second
time you got the tying run 90 feet away
kemp has very big speed
robert and center
so liam hendricks works around trouble
in the eighth sox hold a one run lead
it's three to two hoping liam can get
lowry for the final out here it is
swinging in a miss strike three
hendricks strikes out the side
in the ninth for the second time in the
series but tonight he had to get two
extra outs
and how about the white sox pitching
staff tonight stoney getting out of
multiple jams
well this is a whale of a ball game
tonight luis robert had a big night but
the night belonged to the bullpen
liam on for a five-out save just
blew away
lowry on a fastball away
he struck out the side in the ninth
after a six pitch eighth now that
is closing down a ball game
[Applause]